peu
[Musique]
où
vol oui dépêche toi
ouais
nom de dieu et blesse que tu te
paraissent et la cuisine on faisait des
greffes ali qui bat tout le monde le
philippe labi non mais voir des côtes
j'ai failli me faire tuer moi c'est le
gaz de lacq c'est un gars qui sue promis
vous rendez compte garder
[Musique]
et
oh
[Musique]
l'abus qui montrent la personne est
morte c'est pas possible
philippe aussi jouent pas et restez pas
là messieurs dames oui c'est dangereux
restez pas là
buts à buc est mort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors à l'arrivée
nettoie il repart
[Musique]
je n'ai pas le moindre indice à l'arrêt
souvenir même flou une allusion la porte
quoi tout me serait utile la pâte on
n'avait pas de famille ou alors elle
n'en parlait jamais mais nous on est là
depuis cinq ans seulement
tenez vous devez plutôt demandé aux
professeurs c'est un client d'au moins
10 ans professeur bart est le suivant
drouet généalogistes vous connaissiez la
patronne depuis si longtemps
peut-être que vous pouviez lui dire en
l'absence de testament m ténin notaires
de la défunte
la charge est de retrouver un éventuel
héritier a priori madame bull n'avait
pas de famille et philippe philippe
lecomte était seulement le concubin de
l'alambic conclu ces deux êtres ce mec
comme de jeunes mariés la loi ne tient
pas compte de ce genre d'arrangement
après c'est dommage
pas pour l'instant revenons à madame
bloc de son côté moi je ne vois rien et
il ne parlait que l'un de l'autre mais
qui l'a jamais tel il exactement
exactement elle était bien trop coquette
pour le dire philippe avait 60 ans ça je
le sais je crois que j'étais un petit
peu plus âgés que lui depuis dix ans
vous habitez l'hôtel vous ne vous
souvenez pas d'un mariage d'un
enterrement où il aurait pu aller pas
personne n'est jamais venu les voir
[Musique]
enfin si des amis beaucoup d'amis je
vais vous montrer son bureau peut-être
vous trouverez quelque chose il ya le
coigné aussi allons-y
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous croyez qu'ils vont fermer l'hôtel
pour voir c'est pas nous qui décidons
je sais mais qui décide
l'auteur je pense nous et il faut lui
parler je crois que c'est le monsieur là
bas raccompagné des gaziers quelle
destinée à buc est morte en faisant des
crêpes
je suis sûr qu'elle aurait aimé cette
femme sage et bien une idée de roman
cible
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bref à votre oeuf jusque là mon vieux
rien que c'est pas la peine depuis
l'explosion n'a pas bougé de là ça fait
48 heures qu'il avait bu ni mangé mais
alors monsieur notaire avec la décision
dépend de vous mais quelle décision
celle de fermer l'hôtel jusqu'à présent
ça dépend des surtout du gaz de france
mais les experts viennent de m'affirmer
que la conduite dangereuse et muselé
c'est que tout nouveau risque
d'explosion est écarté
c'était une fuite l enquête se poursuit
ces messieurs font leur rapport en ce
qui concerne l'hôtel alors là je suis
perplexe n'avaient toujours pas trouvé
de testament n'ont ni testament ni
héritiers connus
alors si j'ordonne la fermeture de
l'hôtel je risque de spolier les
éventuels héritiers ah oui le fonds de
commerce peuvent se déprécier
alors je peux compter sur ma chambre il
ya plus ample informé oui enfin si
monsieur et madame le marchand veulent
bien assurer une sorte de gérance
momentanée ces labels soigne sa la
patronne aurait payé mais confirme son
hôtel mais mais dont je crois que j'ai
trouvé une piste
[Musique]
il
sur au téléphone parfois susan boyle
belge s'occuper mais c'est votre forme
c'est nouveau il paraît qu'un d'eux dans
votre famille
[Musique]
alors oui oui comment non à l'eau alors
j'ai cependant les louise pas quoi mais
qu'est ce qui se passe enfin je suis
inquiet moi tu sais ça tombe but qu on
pense à une tentative
je la connais pas je te tente inconnus
alors c'est grave
bon bah ambages à rillieux
et
qu'est ce que c'est que ce cirque qui
m'a coupé avec paris c'est monsieur
leroux qui a perdu sa tante
ouah
[Musique]
c'est
oui
bateau
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
félicitations monsieur l'euro merci mais
de quoi s'agit-il exactement
et d'un héritage monsieur voilà j'avais
une vieille tante
une grande tente à paris elle est morte
accidentellement une explosion de gaz
elle avait à l'hôtel d'un cinquième
arrondissement jeu 6e tout près de
l'odéon et d'après monsieur vendre ou
qui est généalogiste nous sommes c'est
seulement un luthier nous enfin moi
cette petite nièce
puis c'est merveilleux alors bon on la
connaissait pas ce n'est pas la peine de
personnes à l'avoir du chagrin n'est ce
pas mais non c'est pas une blague au
moins absolument pas c'est quand même ça
alors enfin ge
alors voilà une histoire mais c'est quoi
comme hôtel bon alors vous accepté
l'héritage
quelle question ça ne se refuse pas un
héritage justement il par exient encore
de dette ou de feuilles
mais rassurez vous
je suis autorisé par le notaire à vous
dire que l'hôtel dieu qui est une
affaire parfaitement saine et que ses 25
chambres fonctionne tap la rame
nous acceptons un shérif oui enfin c'est
toi qui décides ombres très bien je vous
pourrez donc d'entrer en contact le plus
tôt possible avec m tena voici ses
coordonnées et celle de mon cabinet nous
nous permettrons de vous envoyer nos
honoraires après la conclusion de
l'opération furent bien sûr monsieur c
est ça va chercher dans les combien ça
vaut un horaire de 30% de l'héritage
il a pas les droits de succession
naturellement vous emmerdez pas moins
c'est la loi monsieur je vous rend ces
photos vous étiez déjà très mignon mais
je vous laisse je crois bien qu'on a dit
l'essentiel
et n'oubliez surtout pas l'urgence de la
situation
l'hôtel vu qu enfin votre audel et
fonctionne pour le moment sans direction
grâce à la bonne volonté du personnel
aux mets ça va pas traîner
soyez sans crainte merci beaucoup vous
savez je suis souvent le bienvenu à ce
point là c'est rare
[Musique]
rsa chambre rive gauche
ça va aller chercher dans l'est que je
me renseigne mais ça ça doit bien
tourner autour de 30
peut-être 40 briques laquelle est morte
en faisant décret le jour de la
chandeleur ciel est amusant ça bon allez
viens mais où prendre les mesures qui
s'imposent
toi tu demandes un congé au proviseur
moi je préviens barjac lors de trois
jours à paris ce sera réglé appel
notaire prévient le fonds sera à paris
demain soir et les enfants enfants chez
ma mère il faut quoi être content cela
expliquera qui viennent d'hériter d'une
vieille tante mais non en fait tu m'en
avait jamais parlé
toki d'elle et de l'hôtel bon ce soir
j'ai la tête comme ça avec cette
histoire
il
vous avez un sacré culot vous dit non
mais pas du tout je vous ai demandé un
congé valériane demandé m'avait dit je
pars pour paris et bien non vous ne
partez pas même pas quarante huit heures
un chef de service ne quitte pas son
poste en période d'inventaire et de
renouvellement des stocks
c'est la diversion enfin vous n'êtes pas
d'accord si si si si ça y'a rien de plus
important que le stock
1 mais j'avais pensé qu'en cas de deuil
l'aller rien à [ __ ] de votre tante la
connaissait même pas oui si on me l'a
dit alors pas de bonis mois envoyez
votre femme
foutez moi la paix faites lui confiance
que diable moi je vous fais moins
confiance mais je sais je vous en
remercie d'ailleurs aller n'ont pas non
plus un petit goûter comme vous plaît
monsieur martin qui tue à noter
l'impressionnante r oui et tu te
souviens lors du rendez vous bien sûr
est une signoria sans prévenir un mais
non
je sais d'argent regardent étonnés c'est
ton sac ouvert vois rien de moscou y y
j'écoute gauthier à paris tu sors pas de
soi dommage qu'il ne puisse pas venir
avec moi tu crois pas que tu aurais pu
quand même demandé à marc jeu non non je
réfléchissais trop de responsabilités
alors je vais même pas lui en parler
oui je sais que sur les photos
celle que le généalogiste à trouver dans
le grenier de l'otage j'aimerais que
drôlement mignonne
dans ma femme on te reconnaît pas
beaucoup
et ça qui sait ça
attention si vous n'avez devant la
figure c'est pas c'est ma grand-mère ou
tentent du coup j'en sais rien je ne
connaissais pas que j'étais petit
peut-être avant que la famille la met en
quarantaine
[Musique]
je les comprends les actes et ceux du
moins choqué
auch pas choquer
non mais je comprends simplement quand
vous y soustraire à l'enfant à
l'affluence de
afin d' une
d'une [ __ ] dit le tu vois même le
montre enfin d'une ancienne pour pertes
pour ça que je n'en ai jamais parlé tu
es aussi
chicoine parlons d'autre chose
on associe comme ça
et quel souci pourquoi mais tout va très
bien on vient d'hériter d'une vieille
[ __ ] inconnu enfin je veux dire d'une
vieille tante ont connu et peu de temps
pense ou moi je trouve ça très bien
fais moi plaisir est la voiture et si et
prend un taxi pour rentrer puisque tu me
je conduis très bien j'aime j'aime pas
conduire mais je suis très bien
non j'adore conduire
tu conduis très bas
[Musique]
stéphanie financer votre papa on allait
se mettre à table
excusez moi mais j'ai dû accompagner ma
femme à la gare enfin est-ce qu'on peut
regarder un coq
il y aura six ça suffit pour la vo à
faire alors je dois les touristes
stéphanie elle voulu regarder le
feuilleton américain
ils n'ont pas arrêté de se disputer et
vous on dérange eur/l taylor donc un
poste de [ __ ] qui vous le demande
orale et des enfants dit au revoir et
merci au revoir merci à demain les
enfants avec de l'ancien comment vous
faites pour lire le journal et regarder
la télé en même temps
il
[Musique]
elle
alors j'ai pas eu mon bisous mois
[Musique]
à
à temps
madame buts hugo d'amours j'ai fait mon
voyage j'ai aussi dit la nouvelle
patronne arrive il faut venir la
chercher
ça vous dérange pas que je vous accuse
patronne comme l'abus
mon but
oui c'est comme ça que vous appelez la
bu
en fait quand parler d'elle puisque
qu'on lui parlait on l'appelle efron se
vendent malheur vous savez c'était la
soeur de votre grand mère maternelle
assez tout ça comme il n'avait pas de
vue que vous aussi
la voiture juste devant
non l'école
c'était aussi à peine dix minutes vous
connaissez paris
et puis c'était une femme de coeur et
comprenait tout et savait écouter savez
ce furent un temps d'auxi d'ailleurs des
plus que des pulls à aller tous les ans
les filles ont aussi fait quoi
exactement à l'hôtel un peu tout je suis
un peu de portier
valet de chambre un peu secrétaire je
vais te prend lui aussi ça peut vous
pousser un peu pour la vue du rif unis
pourtant
[Musique]
mais
oh
[Musique]
e
ala hector
notre meilleur de nuit
bonsoir monsieur bonsoir madame appelé
my door
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que tu as
et à
je cherche quoi qu'est ce que tu
cherches
bien la ressemblance
il ya bien y avoir un air de famille
quelques peurs est ce qu'on peut vous
préparer quelque chose il nous reste du
gigot dès ce matin non ma fille j'ai
dîné au wagon restaurant
j'ai surtout très sommeil bon je vous
conduirai partement privé il faut quand
même que je vous montre ainsi souffle et
il faut quand même qu'on lui montre
il
voilà
cela
vous savez
je ne la connaissais pas
voilà le jardin
[Musique]
monsieur philippe arles était fier
c'est lui qui a pratiquement tout
planter et faire que ce soit
s'avère joly
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'été quand il fait beau on sur la table
on mange tous dehors ça y est j'ai
trouvé c'est la démarche
pardon bah oui vous marché comme elles
viennent et c'est par ici
voilà vous étiez vous
salle de bains est ici et là c'est le
bureau bucs
c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelle c'était
son domaine les faisais les factures les
comptes et les fleurs ne vous dérange
pas la nuit
non pas du tout c'est en trois lettres
les a mises et c'est ce que ça peut vous
attend d'eux mais ce que fait très tôt
celle qui fait les départs les petits
déjeuners
bon voilà je vous laisse à demain
patronne à demain six sous
[Musique]
à
vingt sept parties new york houston est
mort jones et non 12 tonnes moi pas
comprendre
ok non tôt ce n'est encore acquis mais
également des anciens quais les briques
et de sang neuf avec byron de bosse en
bosse
la patronne jeanne moment ah ouais une
minute
entré ces clients là je les comprends
pas enfin il y en a un qui est malade et
qui réclament le patron le boss
alors je suppose que le patron enfin la
patronne de speak english
layton a comme quand camuzat space
imposé ni ian paisley ben saada
escargots il faut appeler un docteur non
non french touch risques macro métro
qu'est-ce qui se passe ce monsieur a été
empoisonné par les escarpins et il pense
que docteur français l'empoisonneur a
aussi vous n'êtes pas la brosse ici on
n'est pas des sauvages à morgan chase et
american hospital yumin certaines choses
moi je crois c'est une gueule de bois
bon ben je voulais la cétoine est soit
six sous bonsoir entraîneur à l'hôpital
américain
allô allô oui le thé le but ici nous
avons un client qui a un peu trop bu
autres manger pouvez vous envoyer une
ambulance il vous plait merci pour les
roses
[Musique]
et
mais
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention c'est chaud servi tant
qu'honnête sa cuisante là et comme
disait madame b un bon show fait ça doit
être saignant au nom par mois la
première
madame buxwv s'est toujours servi à la
première ya encore une petite place vous
mettez quoi dans votre souffle est
monsieur blaise l'emmental ou du gruyère
du comté monsieur muller
vous n'avez pas honte pour un citoyen du
valais quand on veut faire un bon
souffle et on met du comté ont la peau
de lehman et bien moi madame but
madame leroux pardon j'habite ici depuis
10 ans et jamais vous entendez jamais je
n'ai raté un seul déjeuner quelle heure
est il une âme à car j'ai un patient
dans dix minutes
notre cabinet est loin d'ici juste
au-dessus chambres 6 vous exercez ici
mais j'ai enfin j'avais un arrangement
avec la butte
je m'asseye monsieur philippe tous les
soirs à cause de son arthrose cervicale
moyennant quoi ont été autorisés à
exercer en chambre c'est ce que je
trouve un cabinet et vous cherchez oui
puis trois ans
oui jamais trouver aussi bien que le 6
j'ai une jolie installations là où un si
ça vous tente un petit coup dhabi cycle
est orthopédique telle clause
d'extension vous invite
il est trop tard pour le souffle et oui
mais pour le faire ou non
bonjour tout le monde
et ce coup ils vont pas bientôt le
boucher à ça dépend de gdf tiens en
parlant du gaz de france j'ai reçu une
lettre de ce matin qu à ma vitrine sera
pas remboursée avant six mois
quant à la pièce montée du mariage
verdurin plus les 150 religieuse bourré
de verre securit ne parlons pas bref en
rond jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient déterminer
les responsabilités quelles
responsabilités
kouao qui a provoqué l'explosion il
devait de la chance vous savez cet
endroit extraordinaire
il se passe quelque chose ici qu'est ce
que vous voulez dire je suis romancier
j'ai souvent des des pannes comme tous
les gens qui écrit je pense depuis des
années en cas de panne
j'allais faire une balade dans paris
comparez plusieurs jours et plusieurs
nuits depuis l'accident je n'ai pas pu
aller un seul cours et puis à 10 heures
c'est le feu je suis tombé sur cet open
je ne sais jamais quitté la réception
puis s'il s'entraîne quatre heures par
jour l'élection et le pouvoir
ok pas de problème là du site et là là
où vous êtes assise elle m'a dit vous
vous cherchez quelque chose
alors j'ai dit en riant oui madame
l'aspiration elle m'a répondu
c'est ici depuis je viens tous les jours
à midi
après déjeuner je monte haut doubs
jusqu'à 7 heures du soir ou du matin
quelle heure est il une finalité palluel
non j'ai un appartement au boulevard
montparnasse
une femme et deux filles l'hôtel c'est
mon bureau un bureau étrange mais
efficace j ai écrit deux romans et un
film qui a très bien marché
l'héritière de la butte
sial nom et plus de thann 6 mai plus de
balade à l'hôtel bucs et à sa nouvelle
patronne un nom à l'hôtel but à l'hôtel
buquet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
assieds toi sur ton siège stéphanie tu
vois rien comme ça à vue puis c'est
dangereux
parti d'un produit c'est pas dangereux
je compte bien aussi bien qu'elle
papa regarde et annoncés soient chassés
gros lieutenant ben on l aurait payé ça
fait plaisir à papi et mamie voir tous
les pièges et embrasserait pape a dit ce
soir tu ne mangeras pas il salonu sans
l'union comme tout le monde quand tu
manges l'oignon non plus à même quand il
ne marche pas
la patience est rouge
arrête fermerait tu me fais peur je le
vois bien il sait rouge
[Musique]
oh ma voiture seriez du tout
non rien de tout ça rien du tout ira est
ma vie ma peinture je brille comme ça
d'ailleurs là sur l'ale ça devait lui
être assez vieux ça mais non c'est pas
vieux
excusez moi monsieur berlin parce que
oui excusez le il n'y a pas fait exprès
ne t'occupe pas de sa maman
et vous allez voir mais ça c'est rien
juste un petit coup de peinture
une fois ça moi-même ni mon petit fils
non merci alors mon grand tu manges avec
nous non non il faut que je m'en aille
je me soirée tarot ah oui on est
vendredi un petit apéro alors non j'ai
pas le temps marie louise heure de paris
tu as des nouvelles
oui oui je vais appeler ce matin alors
l'hôtel il paraît que c'est pas mal mais
on a parlé de minutes elle partait chez
le notaire
sinon il faut que je me sauvais il est
déjà six heures je viens chercher les
gosses demain matin un géant gauche hugo
tu veux comme sent coupable ou non
non merci mais oui ils sont bons mais
non je taisais pour que je file elle et
les enfants soyez sages 1 mais rien
n'est pas la télé trop longtemps couché
les taux un peu inquiète pas bon une
soirée mon grand oui c'est ça bonne
soirée à demain
[Musique]
prudemment
m
[Musique]
à diego dit mais qu'est ce que c'est que
ça c'est du chant ailleurs breizh
tu veux mourir la porte ouais sinon je
suis fou tout ce côté d'agneau par terre
sera l'hommage mondial herman toi tu
attends un troisième lardons tout à fait
un héritage là pour la lardant sait
jamais mais l'héritage c'est sûr salif
n'diaye vient de nous les verts janvier
ça s'arrose à wall street
qu'est-ce qui se passe leroux hérite
voilà avant-hier chapon que j'ai une
tante qu'elle vient de mourir et qu'elle
nous laisse un hôtel comme comme ça
tranquille comment ça un hôtel mais où
25 chambres à paris dans le 6e et
remarques je ne sais pas beaucoup plus à
marie-louise devait me rappeler je
loupais tu vas pas installé à paris ont
été fouillés mois et à paris en plus
non je vends gens qu'est ce point à la
ligne un petit voyage aux seychelles ou
au mexique avec marie-louise pour
marquer le coupé tout est dit si vous
voulez mon avis le champagne on devrait
se faire après le sauter déjà tiède
tu as passé sa vie à servir cette jeune
fille de la maison voilà j'en ai
peut-être on connaît mais michel c'est
vrai rita je suis contre question de
principe et bien refuse le par principe
si tu n'en veux pas mais vous êtes con
il ya des principes il ya la réalité
c'est toujours pareil il est contre
l'héritage jusqu'à ce qu'ils méritent
quoi mais non je suis contre les impôts
je les paye je prends la pilule mais met
il en prend
[Applaudissements]
pas moi pourquoi y'a des pilules pour
les mecs c'est plutôt ta femme qui en a
besoin
seul à paris dans un tel club hongrois
peut-être des bourgeois a surtout à
paris tu peux être sûr qu'elle attentes
elle est un peu tôt hier soir là au
contraire alors au contraire le genre
bonjour ou autres outils comment tout ce
qu'on demande c'est que tu nous héberge
dans ton clan mais à chaque fois
et naturellement tu nous fournit la main
d'oeuvre féminine
[Rires]
je crois qu'on est là pour jouer aux
cartes
non allez au seul talent ce carton on
peut plus jouer avec leur nom
il a trop de pognon magloire sévère
[Musique]
bien ou la formidable attendant on va la
retourner vers la mare mais la croatie
hongrie pour moi al-qosi comme ça newey
la toute neuve commerçant doit conduire
à carouge et un talent comme il ya du
cognac qu'un point coup un homme et j'ai
eu mal mais rien de regarder sa cuisse
monsieur l'on veut faire ils mettent le
doigt sous la flotte est tombé dans les
pommes ce qu'on a en tête la glace non
mais s'il va tomber il faut le conserver
ou non me fait quelque chose mais il ya
bien une pharmacie de garde quoi
personne avec un stick pour les fermes
et garou a agi mois dans michael cheval
stéphane va chercher ta bagnole je lis
un téléphone de l'hôpital dès lors qu'on
arrive nous prenons et l'enfant
l'hôpital et à une coupelle doit arrêter
pas de conneries ça rien contre calais
boit un coup
allez est la montée dans la voiture de
troupes j'avais 12 ans oui voilà elle
est bien gentille
oui j'arrive tout ça on s'en fout de
tout cela
[Musique]
allo ici l'hôtel but
oui on dort toujours aussi bien chez
vous madame merci j'ai bien connu votre
temps vous savez c'est la septième année
que je viens à bancs et même ça fait
quatre ans qu'on nous annonce un
ascenseur remarque est montée jusqu'au
troisième étage c'est dur pour nos
vieilles jambes et voilà excusez moi
mais ce sera le responsable du groupe
vous devez savoir si on lui fait 10 % de
réduction vous savez ça mieux que moi en
train est ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que la butte leur faisait toujours et
bien fait comme l'abus qu à le menu du
jour j'ai acheté des ris de veau était
très bon marché ce matin
c'est très bien en place ris de veau
gendron c'est comment bon je suis un peu
à ma manière coib mondiale et nouvelle
les girolles hier c'était sensationnel
on peut voir ris de veau jaf outils aux
pruneaux j'adore ça et on s'en va au
danemark ait jamais
le l'hôtel beach écoutent oui oui madame
c'est votre mari alors côtier où
étais-tu j'étais appelé toute la nuit
quoi à l'hôpital mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe bye est ce parce que j'ai failli
perdre un doigt
j'ai eu un accident non avec une chaise
chez michèle alliot marie louis jamet
barillot je veux tu m'écoutes oui bien
sûr je t'écoute ya un peuple ou noyau
mme p flou qu'est ce que c'est c'est là
et starlettes celle du 17
elle s'endort en fumant elle met boulet
de la toux le soul et puis et c'est
passé qu'elles font ils ça semble
bizarre dans la simple c'est la femme de
chambre
mais toi c'est grave les docteurs savent
pas si je vais récupérer la souplesse de
mon index
le second ne quitte pas alors oui vous
l'avez marbella dix minutes sous
surveillance et 11h38 à l'eau gauthier
mais qu'est ce qui se passe quand est-ce
que tu reviens mais ça va ça va ils sont
chez maman alors t'as vu de la terre bon
ça va ces règles c'est réglé ils à mes
envies mais d'ici là il pense que gérant
est indispensable alors il m'a suggéré
de mettre une annonce il ya qu'à fermer
l'hôtel justement il pense que non il ya
le personnel il faudrait leur pipe
ils sont très gentils tu sais moi je
suis pratiquement un film sur moi je
veux que tu reviennes je sais que ça
c'est une maison de fouste hôtel bon
alors tu reviens encore t'es bien du
souci pour pas grand chose
200 millions de fonds de commerce et 200
millions d'immobilier quoi coiffer ce
que tu dis l'hôtel en tous vos 4
millions nom de dieu mais tu pouvais pas
le dire plutôt 400 oui non mais t'es sûr
c'est pas vrai c'est pas que je ne bouge
pas je ne fais rien je le fais
car
dans une
oh
m
quatre cent briques
[Musique]
nom de dieu blaise qu'est ce qui se fera
c'est l'accusé des crêpes à l'équipe à
tout le monde
philippe la butte
l'abus qui manque la petite reine est
morte alors c'est pas possible
qui sait ça tant de buts d'après
monsieur vendre ou qui est généalogiste
comme c'est ça l'amitié nous mais c'est
merveilleux
disons que je ne l'avais jamais parlé
de qui
l hôtel à la victoire noté hier de nuit
voilà c'est là
vous savez
je ne la connaissais pas tu vas pas te
reste à l'abri nous te fous tu me vois
hôtelier mois et appareils apple non je
vends j'encaisse point d'aline il que tu
triches pas comme la dernière fois des
numéros ce cognac ce commerçant mais y'a
qu'à fermer l'hôtel tout c'est bien plus
simple des indemnités c'est bien lui
aussi pour pas grand chose
c'est quand même beaucoup d'argent 400
briques 4 g/t sur niort dans se
prendrait surtout ne bougez pas on ne
fait rien jamais à l'hôtel bucs et à sa
nouvelle pas prendre à l'hôtel où
logeait à l'hôtel but
- tu vas à tanger quoi pas de truc il
utile d'engager trois mètres pour faire
le gaulois d'un salon ça c'est certain
comment voilà voilà les syndicats
suivent pas et quand les syndicats
suivent pas les entrepôts dans les
jambes coupées un saloperies ce prix
demain à rennes on parle anglais
je suis désolé mais c'est rien c'est
bien le seul malheur des technocrates
mon cher les syndicats n'ont rien
compris en fait là tenez moi en disant
de sofitel disons que ce filet mais j'ai
d'abord été et chef de réception après
directeur adjoint et puis j'ai passé
cinq ans comme general manager au
holiday inn de porto rico et maintenant
maintenant je suis directeur de l'hôtel
hilton à marseille fashion
robert sociale gauthier deux roues je
suis moi même un peu dans l'hôtellerie
un peu je suis propriétaire d'un hôtel à
paris
vous connaissez la question carter
bazire que parker moi ma spécialité ce
serait plutôt la la promotion de vent ah
oui promotion direction management ont
soit pas de ce problème la gestion je
viendrai qu'on arrive pas ouais mais
kechiche veut tout tout à fait d'accord
les mâles couteau le couple attendait
mais je suppose qu'à là bas à porto rico
question malheur vous étiez à votre
affaire al assad est pas si facile
une clientèle anglaise pectine un
personnel qui à blaise pagnol
heureusement je trouverai pas fait
attention
alors pardon je suis désolé les achever
je suis arrangé cela je crois que c'est
utile mademoiselle peut pas faire
attention non c'est vous qui m'avez
amenée principale raison pourquoi c'est
ma poupée contre le siège monsieur est
trempé c'est rien c'est rien à plus de
vingt ans plus tard s'asséchera tout
seul
[Musique]
vous prendrez du café monsieur oui s'il
vous plaît
2 merci tenez prenez ma tarte aux
cerises qu'on voudrait pas si si si si
j'insiste et dites moi à paris c'est
facile de trouver un bon gérant d'hôtel
ce qu'une question de flair teulé parra
pas plus tard que la semaine dernière
j'ai engagé un commercial le type se
présente dans mon bureau je fais je le
regarde je retire ma cravate la balance
sur la table jeudi relève en deux mois
ça en deux minutes j'ai vu à qui j'avais
affaire
[Applaudissements]
à
je vous présente à tous monsieur lourds
mon mari je blesse gendron notre chef
je m'excuse de vous donner la main
gauche mais blaise est resté plus tard
aujourd'hui
normalement il part après le déjeuner
puisque a pas de ligne hector lui est
arrivé plutôt l'habitude et n'arrive
qu'à 8 heures c'est notre veilleur de
nuit
bienvenue à l'hôtel bucs messieurs les
directeurs et chefs à la main gauche
ça c'est purification elle est femme de
chambre à l'hôtel depuis les accords
messier dépouillé l'ouverture désormais
100 ha ben je pense purification avec un
nom comme ça on peut vous faire
confiance
c'est sous le marchand ma femme
antoinette six sous et monsieur muscle
de fort de france 1975
ah oui ah ouais je m'intéresse beaucoup
au culturisme bas pop pas pour moi mais
enfin je trouve ça bien je trouve que
c'est fin c'est
ça encourage les jeunes à faire de la
gymnastique en toilettes prépare son
doctorat en droit
bon voilà je crois que tu connais tout
le monde
il ne manque que jean-françois l'autre
veilleur de nuit il vient trois fois par
semaine j'oubliais truc le cocker des
trucs il se cache sous ce mode depuis
puisqu'elle est morte la butte
c'est comme ça que tout le monde
l'appelle ici
oui ça va mieux non non il eût pu en
écharpe
gauthier il et il vient de sortir
passez-moi stéphanie oui si à ma chérie
[Musique]
c'est un tir a dit il quand il faut se
souvenir ému par quelques jours ou plus
tard à la fin de la semaine
oui monsieur deux candidats viennent
d'arriver pour l' annonce qu'elle
annonce celle du figaro pour le gérant
j'arrive je les ai fait entrer dans le
bureau alors faire dans mon petit orge
bientôt manger
qu'est ce que c'est un giro a géré en
bas c'est un monsieur qui organise un
petit peu tout comme ils directrice
d'école mais pour l'hôtel tu comprends
laisse moi faire les gérants c'est mon
rayon
je sais exactement le genre de type
qu'il nous faut c'est sûr c'est que je
viens avec toi j'ai eu le flair pour ce
genre de truc je sais comment juger
quelqu'un en deux minutes
mais je préfère être seul bien prendre
le type en main d'homme
bonjour messieurs puis je demandais à
l'un d'eux vous de me laisser seul avec
l'autre vous pouvais m'attendre dans le
rôle comment voulez je vous en prie
vous sentez pas bien si si c'est vrai
qu'il fait une chaleur ici
regardez-moi ça mais c'est votre cravate
mais c'est ça dans des moments cravate
puisque c'est votre cravate elle vous
appartient je peux pas où la bande
ça peut vous paraître bizarre mais c'est
une prise de contact
un test voilà c'est un test une façon
pour moi de juger vos capacités de
gestion et bons rapports avec les gens
voyons je te dresser un bilan
faire le planning des réservations
organiser le personnel remplir les
fiches de sécurité sociale composé les
menus calmer les clients difficiles à la
rigueur faire face à une situation
d'urgence
je suis incapable de vous vendre une
cravate même la vôtre vous êtes malade
mon vieux pour vous soigner
[Musique]
police sécurité du territoire mon
adjoint à l'inspecteur fabre je peux
jeter un coup d'oeil sur le registre de
vos réservations
oui merci ballet même pas jolie cette
cravate une cravate invendables c'est
quand même incroyable
le manque d'imagination enfin c'est
pourtant simple
cette cravate et non seulement fabriquer
à hong kong avec la soie la plus
délicate issus des glandes salivaires
des vers à soie asiatiques les plus
prolifiques du monde
mais encore sa triple triple sûrs
parfaitement triple vous croyez que
c'était une vulgaire doublure n'est ce
pas eh bien à cette superbe cravate n
ont pas doublé mais triplé avec une
autre une bombe de tissus écrus voilà
que voici
et qui maintient la tenue de la cravate
ben on pourrait peut-être arrêter les
conneries et parler de l'hôtel l'hôtel
bucs j'en ai souvent entendu parler
c'est un endroit merveilleux que vous
avez là et je crois enfin je pense que
je suis quelqu'un qui ferait tout pour
préserver le charme le côté personnel
nous parler anglais anglais italien
allemand espagnol
j'ai dirigé un hôtel un peu dans le
genre de celui ci à londres et un autre
à monaco n'est pas monsieur
jean-philippe juve et oui n'est pas
monsieur givet est ce que vous êtes
homosexuel
je ne vois pas ce que ça avoir assez ça
a tout à voir parce que je déteste les
homosexuels tous
bah oui tous il vous en connaissez
beaucoup
aucun
je mens pardon pour la tasse de gérance
il ajouté vous pouvez y aller la place
est libre vous attendez demain monsieur
et madame rodrigo herrera si c'est écrit
la liste des numéros de téléphone que
ces gens vont appeler durant leur séjour
nous intéresse quelle liste je comprends
pas vos clients les herrera les
téléphones de l'hôtel je suppose oui eh
bien vous aurez la gentillesse de
dresser la liste de leurs communications
et nous les remettre vous plaisantez
doit inquiéter pas fait un procès des
routiniers
je sais vous n'êtes pas encore au
courant mais vous apprendrez vite au
revoir madame leroux chérie je te
présente monsieur bruno notre nouveau
gérant gauthier vienne s'est passé un
louis je te présente monsieur boury
notre nouveau gérant ou sauter
aujourd'hui madame messieurs bruno
commencera demain matin quelques jours
pour l'autre point et non à 3 bourque
tais toi toi comment tu es toi on essaie
tous les cockers sont odieux ce type est
une perle
si je pouvais je me prendrai les mains
bon de changer on dîne en ville
gauthier mais si tu il vient de se
passer quelque chose qui
quelle heure est il 19h10 monsieur
woerth le bateau mouche peu à temps
allait pas les pieds non non je vous
appelle un taxi
le bateau mouche sur ces entités sa part
fait math habillé ma chérie
ondine sur le bateau mouche
amap qui est héritière s'est dévêtue
mais non c'est formidable de bouger une
femme par amour elle s'apercevra pour
exterminer ricker non surtout dix ans
[Musique]
et ce bruit aux truffes et le tourteau
maison
non mais sincèrement est-ce que j'ai une
tête ou plutôt un bras à manger du
tourteau pardon
[Musique]
donc
je ne regrette jamais quoi d'or
on n'exclut pas nous ton magasin mon
lycée tout quoi notre vie qu'elle
rejette rien pour jour de la terre est
notre goût mais sur un corps de marie
louise
qu'est ce que tu racontes marie-louise
on parle toujours comme si j'étais
retardé je racontais rien je te parle
c'est normal pour un peu plus de faire
le point de temps en temps de se
remettre en question ah bon
ah non là ça sont l'expression à la mode
qui m'exaspère et justement pas question
de remettre en question et que ce soit
[Musique]
je peux pas essayer de passer ton g un
peu plus calmement je peux pas
on casse une passe de crabes ont la
casse tant dans la casbah calmement
[Musique]
quotes-parts et puis j'ai commander un
repas entièrement mou pour ne rien avoir
un coupé à pousser ou à casser parce que
j'avais envie de faire un dîner
tranquille avec ma femme et ton idée
d'un dîner tranquille avec moi c'est
d'en coller le maître d'hôtel d'admirer
le paysage mais si je commence une
conversation mais j'avais aussi vite ma
parole
c'est vrai tu as raison excuse moi c'est
cette histoire avec la police en a
tellement énervé que je me rendrai en
bois
[Musique]
tout simplement parce qu'on nous demande
de venir indicateurs ça me paraît quand
même curieux que tu mets tout le monde
et indicateur
il ya d'un côté des flics de l'autre les
bandes et et au mieux tout une foison
d'indicateurs qui est de la police parce
qu'ils paient les impôts pour qu'elle
défende
je suppose que la mousse de brochet pour
monsieur voilà
[Musique]
oh
alors pour toi y arriver sic ces
indicateurs et les bandits non c'est une
simplification qua non je veux dire que
le rôle du citoyen est d'aider la police
voilà part évidemment ça c'est plus le
problème
d'ailleurs avec toi tout est simple j'ai
l'impression que pour toi tout est
compliqué c'est l'héritage qui te montre
la tête ou quoi
non enfin je te laisse seuls quatre
jours à paris et je te retrouve
complètement complètement quoi
heureusement j'ai trouvé ce bourrine au
dimanche on entre bourque et la vie
reprend comme si de rien n'était pas de
grosses têtes pas perrette et le pot au
lait on attend que faute elles soient
vendues sans rien changer
enfin je vais m'en occuper mais cette
vente parce que ce pli notaire long du
mât parlait il est très bien où le
sûrement pas un génie des affaires et
toi
tu es un génie des affaires tiens voilà
pour l'addition remet tout en question
tout seul fait de colonnes et pour à
droite les contrats gauche tu me vends
résultats planquette demain moi je
rentre
voilà comme grammaire
je
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
[Musique]
je vous ai tous convoqués ici pour que
monsieur boury novo communiqué un
certain nombre de mesures à prendre afin
de donner à l'hôtel bucs la gestion qui
s'imposent
l'aqua la gestion la direction a si la
direction' 6 6 1 tiennent au il ya
bientôt 48 heures que j'ai eu le plaisir
d'entrer dans mes fonctions de gérant de
cet établissement
9h10 exactement il met très vite apparu
qu'un certain laxisme s'était installé
dans cet hôtel et que des mesures
urgentes se devait d'être prise
tout d'abord les chambres suppression
des boîtes de mouchoirs en papier
gratuite
vous remarquerez qu elles sont vides à
chaque départ
il pourrait pas les remettre en place
après l'utilisation non bien sûr mais il
pourrait aussi se dispenser de les vider
systématiquement en partant les
corbeilles de fruits alors là madame but
qu'un système est bien plus de
corbeilles de fruits dans les chambres
ça coûte une fortune
de même que les fleurs les roses en plus
toujours des roses t madame bucs avait
un arrangement avec le fleuriste chaque
plateau de petit déjeuner bien plus de
rose thé sur les plateaux de petits
défauts c'est pas rentable voyons et
tout le monde s'en fiche
ne voyez pas ça même que monsieur
lévesque les canadiens louis les marchés
dorénavant il mangera ses croissants
sont croissants un croissant suffit ah
oui il ya aussi cette histoire de de
miel du gâtinais alors ça madame bucs
madame buquet mort de monsieur le
marchand
il y a aussi le cas en juin vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir madame leroux qu'il est
absolument interdit d'exercer une
profession dans une chambre d'hôtel
c'est une femme très sympathique ça fait
des années que c'est absolument illégal
chère madame vous pouviez avoir une
amende
oui ciao j'ai encore la main de monsieur
n'ont rien d'illégal il a dû tomber sur
les deux japonaises vous avais pourtant
dit deriez mettre dedans
de combien majoré vous les notes de
téléphone va pour ça j'ai vérifié nous
démontrons à 40% comme tous les autres
hôtels madame bucs qui est morte
trouvais que c'était du vol
c'est le pourcentage habituel dites-moi
antoinette c'est madame but qui vous
avait installé dans ses deux chambres du
dernier étage ces deux champs ou un peu
rafistolé sera chèrement pour des
clients mais c'est très pratique de
loger six sous et aux toilettes à
domicile il ya une pièce au sous-sol
voulait dire la cave au avec quelques
aménagements ont c'est une question
qu'il faudra envisager sérieusement vous
comprenez monsieur leroux deux chambres
à 90 francs petit déjeuner compris enfin
nous verrons ça fait partie de la
deuxième phase de mesures
la deuxième phase à blaise
justement je voulais aborder avec vous
le plus grand problème celui de la table
d'hôte à
m
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
pardon monsieur bonne j'aurais nussa
faurecia fait l'achat en mourrait pas
tord c'est oui tout de suite pas au top
de kehl à madame but qui est décédée
madame oui une chambre à deux lits
le 28 attendez je vais regarder mais
corps oui c'est possible
grand gibier voilà c'est noté excusez
moi le jour de la chandeleur
elle faisait des crêpes et paf tout a
explosé je suis enfin ma femme et sa
nièce à qui ai-je l'honneur
airelle à rodrigo herrera a initié le
comté oui mais lui aussi c'était une
grosse explosion et un ennui de plus
impossible lecoutre la chambre 14 et
plus libre à la case non plus d'ailleurs
nous sommes placés faut déjà vu l'année
dernière ça ne fait rien consuelo y
avoir une erreur un problème un sac de
noeuds monsieur herrera madame consommer
l'eau
vous êtes là pour plusieurs jours locaux
des anciens comme les olives à madame
qu'on se fait lober rien de toute façon
sensée nous arrangerons autrement mon
mari a raison ça ce serait plus pareil
c'est nous qui nous arrangerons nous
avons déplacé un client n'est ce pas
gauthier voilà 6 ou va vous accompagner
vous savez depuis douze ans de
connaissons de chemin
comment
regardez blais de la flèche
anne safran kg et pourtant madame je
disais toujours faut manger un saison
bien mais en saison
c'est vrai aujourd'hui les gens veulent
des artichauts en juillet des asperges
en décembre qui des girolles toute
l'année alors forcément ça vient de
californie
ça n'a pas de vous séduire un yes de
madame but
alors ça y est vous l'avez trouvé voilà
c'est vous les rivières bravo je suis
content pour toi
et puis pour moi aussi parce que moi
aussi j'ai ri tard voyez vous avez une
petite ardoise six mois ben ouais j'ai
marché parce que blaise et mon copain et
puis c'était quelques à la patronne
alors même dans la tombe
j'allais pas lui couper les vivres à
l'abus qu attendait voila voila depuis
début janvier ça fait 4290 frantour oui
parce que l'accident s'était de février
à la 10e' madame but qu'à l'habitude de
payer le dernier mardi de chaque mois
ça fait deux mois c'est une banque de
bourg-en-bresse ça va quand même
elle venait elle même c'était un
prétexte pour venir jusqu'ici qu'est-ce
qu'elle pourra dès son pied la vieille
ici un tel flairé elle renifle est tout
elle se faisait jamais avoir un blaze
merci merci c'est fait c'est vrai que ça
sent bon et vendredi 1 avant le rugby à
lui
[Musique]
leur attaque pour demain ça va ce qu'il
faut pour aujourd'hui c'est le poisson
surtout la bouillabaisse j'adore ça
ouais j'avais dans la tête émergeant en
colère maintenant va pour la
bouillabaisse hyper henry est ce qu'il
faut
[Musique]
2200 francs exactement avec la
bouillabaisse évidemment mais c'est que
vous ne semblez pas du tout à votre
tante ont marqué ressemble à personne
avec son grand chapeau ses cheveux
rouges une sacrée bonne femme s'en mêle
et philippe une bonne chose aussi qu'il
soit parti lui il raconte une semaine
sans aide humble est est d'accord
l'autre
peter genre
ça y est resté bien qu'il ait plus
jamais de partir nous amène à et qu'il
avait deux enfants une femme de côté
d'arcachon des représentants vont donc
un jour est arrivé à l'hôtel je sens que
c'est vers les années jeunesse en cinq
ans pour le composent des divas ça va
pas produire face à l'hôtel montana et
l'envoyer là qu'étaient les familles
bordelaises
et puis ça a été le coup de foudre
réciproque
il faut croire parce que deux jours
après la cité la chambre numéro 10 et
légumes et aragon t il été celle à vue
il n'a jamais pu quitter même pas 24
heures sa femme et ses enfants
rien qu'on tapait pour lui c'est drôle
je n'ai jamais connu il t'apprend pour
madame l'euro/franc suisse quelque chose
non non non non non non non non non
c'est une tradition et lot c'était pour
la patronne mais ici c'est moi
des aliens d'exécution je voulais vous
dire vous savez bourinos havas par
coller la rolls foutent en l'air
[Musique]
pardon je ne sais si c'est un oubli ou
une décision mais il ya plus une gaine
pour le petit déjeuner oui nous avons
remplacé par un jet de groseilles je te
laisse la gelée de groseilles
[Musique]
ça vous dérange pas que le surcoût ça
ici non au contraire les immondes yeux
oui monsieur morineau allô allô allô oui
oui oui je sais mais nous avons supprimé
mais vous en trouverez la pharmacie du
coin
bon bon bon si c'est urgent à ce
problème je vous en fais remonter mais
c'est la dernière fois monté une boîte
de mouchoirs en papier aux américains
lucas elle fait un scandale c'est quand
votre concours
la semaine prochaine lundi à madame âge
on sera déjà à bourque
j'ai pris monsieur bourillot bonjour
bonjour monsieur jugent trop bas
bon je vais au 15 et je vais m'entraîner
une heure six à douze mois
oui un calleur on peut naître entre de
la faculté rosa le vin s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
ou le nouveau patron
quand chercher c'est moins vrai la
scandale commente une seconde de ban
depuis quand il paraît que c'est la
nouvelle question alors on peut ne plus
laver les cheveux maintenant et ça veut
dire mais c'est une mesure d'économie
minable on n'est pas la soupe populaire
ici cinq jabeur breach of poland stein
un évidement si la sainte-chapelle fermé
midi
[Musique]
voilà vous mais où étiez-vous passé
j'arrive des galeries du meubles
fonctionnels à la porte de bercy
oui je leur ai commandé 25 chambres à
coucher les mêmes oui on va essayer de
se débarrasser un peu de toutes ces
vieilleries
ça manque de ce temps dit ici on
trouvait pas non
sos s'il te plaît agathe téléphone à
maman qu'elle nous force à boire du lait
plein de petit pot quand tu y es tu
viens m'aider
tu sais rester affectueuses asie
attention on doit aux chapelles un taxi
parce que 40 minutes
pas la peine si si nous accompagne à la
gare avec la camionnette tu as vu les
enfants oui je crois qu'ils en avaient
appelé à cette chute en mer je suis
resté 18 ans peuvent y être resté quinze
jours encore oublié ta robe de chambre
enfin je suis quand même contente de
rendre bien plus qu'à attendre
bon il tient bien les choses en main et
sur wii est un type qui a de la poigne
toujours quelques petites fautes surtout
avec des gens livrés à eux-mêmes et
habitués aux excentricités d'une vieille
dame un peu folle noël était bien en
main sa manière entrée
eh bien vous dire adieu nous serions pas
parti sans les purifications c'est vous
qui partez on m'a mis à la porte on
nathalie il paraît qu'il y ait l'âge de
la retraite mais ça n'empêche pas que
votre colis non c'est une corniche entre
l'alcool à brûler une corniche on m'a
fait centre pompidou et qui ne se plante
pas pour terra enfin de toutes les
manières il se contenter des mânes allez
vous rendre à madrid pas barcelone a
dépouillé que madame c'est plus pareil
ici vous avez des économies purification
hausse a pas de problème vous aime
peut-être déjà là-bas petit appartement
à madrid d'un photon je veux dire à
barcelone et puis ça va de mieux en
mieux un bain le fascisme mesure n'est
mais parlez pas du facisme et messier ne
savait pas c'est que c'est que les
fassis mme moyer cgt vous dire une sauce
c'est que franco affaires l'espagne
brienon est en train de les faire à
votre hôtel
[Musique]
webber non plus complètement fou
peut-être mais je me sens mieux vue d'un
torchon mais il faudrait de l'eau chaude
place vous rendez compte et ça devait
arriver
je vous prie d'accepter ma démission non
taisez vous plaisent personne de
démissionner c'est à six mois mais non
c'est un malentendu il ya toujours
quelques petits flottements au début
mais ça c'est normal on aura jamais de
sochi roi tant que je serai cuisinier
dans cette maison et tant que vous
n'aurez pas compris ce qu'est le chef
ici le chef des bois oui c'est moi le
chef c'est lui mais c'est monsieur pour
ino qui commande
alors mesdames il ya un monsieur qui
veut demander le décret de la police oui
donc bien celui là
mais ses clients j'étais pourtant bien
sûr d'eux à la voilà nous avons tous
noté
il ne suis pas trop fan de retard pour
le déjeuner non non je crois même
qu'aujourd'hui ça va commencer un petit
peu plus tard vous pouvez pas savoir non
monsieur larose était aussi hargneux
valais sinon pourquoi louvre la tour
eiffel la tour d'argent
l'hippodrome de longchamp moi j'ai passé
ce qu'on m'a demandé vous ne pouvez pas
notre chance c'est même pas à noter ici
c'est un dortoir un capharnaüm une
maison de tincques monsieur bruno c'est
très maladroit ce que vous faites là
madame leroux quand on travaille dans
l'hôtellerie
il est certaines conventions qu'il faut
respecter
je ne suis pas dans l'hôtel vous avez
entendu ici c'est pas un hôtel c'est un
dortoir c'est une maison dingue mais on
traite les clients comme des amis comme
des suspects
salut à ma caisse qui se passait rien à
bouffer je vais vous faire une petite
salade de boeuf en vitesse s'il reste du
pot-au-feu diego et moi ça si c'est pas
un malheur pour il a trouvé les moyens d
salies et le ma moquette
c'est boulineau il est parti oui
heureusement
comment heureusement mais c'est une
catastrophe
nous en sommes au même point que le jour
de mon arrivée je parlais du fis j'ai le
rouge qu'est ce que vous voulez vous
acheter votre hôtel vous voulez visiter
non non je connais ah bon on est passé
dans mon bureau
voilà je tiens à vous dire tout de suite
l'hôtellerie moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
toi ça tombe bien moi non plus c'est
pourquoi je me permets d'être aussi
direct avec vous ça fait dix ans que je
guette cet emplacement à vous aviez déjà
contacté madame b déjà contacté mais
depuis dix ans je venais d'avoir tous
les six mois et régulièrement je me
faisais foot alain portes comme un
malpropre
c'était une vieille emmerdeuse non je
n'aime pas fond j'avais des doutes
commun alors moi cet hôtel je démolis
carrément et je construis un immeuble de
douze étages
il ya des studios de grand standing
voilà les plans dans les deux cas et
kitchenette faux semis des poutres
apparentes vide en dur automatique 23
mètres carrés où l'on remarqué je vous
dis ça moi ça ne me regarde pas et une
fois que j'ai vendu aux gros tiers
vous habitez la province bourg-en-bresse
j'ai pas envie de garder un petit
pied-à-terre à paris au nom alors on
obtient sûrement pas
[Musique]
madame l'euro
oui
[Musique]
merci
mais de quoi monsieur herrera
il voudrait vous raconter une petite
histoire venez vous asseoir de minutes
c'était en 1969 nami seine-escaut lien
nous avait parlé des hôtels manquait
c'était
qui les a reçus elle nous a fait une
drôle d'impression
cette façon de vous regarder à la fois
ironique et pénétrante
et lendemain elle vient me trouver là
haut la police sortez d'ici
il me souvient elle m'a dit c'est moi
qui décide qui coucher chez moi à l'effi
mahé théologie
il répondu
le soir elle a rendu son verdict seul à
huis clos dans la chambre et pathos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
ça me réveille nos tous les arts
[Musique]
dites moi monsieur rire ça vous ennuie
règne parler d'elle encore en danger
leur à peu près ça vaut 20 euros c'est
parfait vous pourrez même rentré à bourg
ce soir nous avons déjà raté notre train
mais il ya un avion pour lyon dans la
soirée je crois ah ben si vous voulez
tuer le modem secrétaires de s'occuper
de vos billets je vais demeurer chez le
notaire
mais c'est très gentil mais alors
d'accord chez m thénac dans une heure
[Rires]
et le personnel quoi quoi le personnel
qu'est ce qu'ils vont devenir mes pages
tapé les indemnités
ce sera mon contrat tu as eu évidemment
que je suis sûr tu me demande tout le
temps si je suis sûr on dirait vraiment
pas que j'ai un traité une affaire de
350 millions tu te rends compte ma et
louise 350 millions de centimes
je me rends compte c'est formidable mais
mais mais comment peut-on dire mais
comme ça à 350 prix qui vous tombent
dessus sans même avoir de chagrin sans
perdre quelqu'un qui a bu que je sais
pas moi
moralement raser le thème sais pas
pourquoi tu emplacement désagréable
enfin il ya trois semaines on savait
même pas qu'il existait son hôtel
oui une fois de plus tu as raison
voilà trois cent cinquante mille fois
soit 10% du total
c'est quand même la première fois qu'on
nous fait un chèque de 35 millions à le
mettre à thénac va enfin s'occuper les
papiers pour l'enregistrement
et puis je pense que d'ici une quinzaine
de jours à monsieur et madame le route
pourront peut-être revenir à paris vers
le 25 de ce mois vous nous téléphoner
pas de problème non mais j'ai tout l'été
soyez tranquilles bon chéri il faut pas
qu'on rate au sida vient vous avez une
voiture vous accompagne oui mais nous
sommes déjà très en temps vous inquiétez
pas on y va m moi j'ai jamais raté un
avion de la plupart des douleurs livre
aussi mais je ne sais pas si vous versez
vous qui avez les billets
moi ça ah bah oui c'est vrai bagage en
très peur bas ont été dites pour trois
jours
[Musique]
à
raté l'avion payage pitot colette
voulait m'appeler ma belle-mère à
bourg-en-bresse
on a bien un petit verre pourquoi de la
maison mais ça veut dire quoi ça non
c'est pour vous pour moi a pour moi
et j'insiste oublié jusqu'aux gros
chèque
1 oui purification vous êtes d y arriver
nous comment les jardins on dirait que
vous attendiez oui on a raté l'avion
les problèmes de circulation
oui je vous raconterai non non ça se
passe bien
j'ai passé un gars pour je sers halal en
quatre jours skol cole est un pilote il
ya une chambre ici toute l'année c'est
bonjour tard toilettes
elle est là une surprise pour elle
comment ce n'est pas au courant et au
courant de quoi
elle est morte ce alors c'est la
première fois que je reste si longtemps
sont venir évidemment j'attendais une
réponse est vendeuse madame leroux la
nièce de la butte
toutes mes condoléances sur madame merci
monsieur voyez-vous votre tante était
une très vieille amie et moi et comme
j'ai travaillé pendant de nombreuses
années opposé chaud si elle m'avait
chargé de faire pour elles certaines
démarches auprès d'eux enfin maintenant
ça s'appelle l'environnement et vue sur
ce une réponse aujourd'hui
quelle réponse j'ai bien fait je
classement de lodève le classement
d'hôtel
monsieur leroux mon mari monsieur ben
asher coutal vincent coutal vous parlez
du classement de l'hôtel et oui il n'ya
pas loin de 10 ans et ça je me rappelle
était encore au ministère à l'époque que
madame bucs voulait refaire la toiture
ça coûtait une fortune alors comme ce
petit immeuble est un bijou qui doit
dater des environs de la guerre de 70 je
pense elle a eu l'idée d'en demander le
classement ce qui était aussi pour elle
une manière définitive de se débarrasser
des promoteurs immobiliers eh bien j'ai
eu la réponse ce matin
officieusement bien entendu et alors
mais les papiers officiels arriveront
dans peu de temps
pauvre l'udc elle aura eu sa toiture
elle ne leur a pas su alors vous êtes
son héritière si je comprends bien vous
savez un hôtel du dix neuvième classe et
vous avez droit à l'état davantage tous
les frais d'entretien de l'extérieur de
l'immeuble sont à la charge de l'état
toiture ravalement fonda
mais attendez je dois avoir un dossier
type dans ma voiture je vais le chercher
[Musique]
oh
qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sous
il
et dans la tombe de se débrouiller pour
[ __ ] à la porte
je vous avais dit que c'est une firme r2
[Musique]